un edificio en llamas otros en ruinas
señales de que la línea del frente en el
este de ucrania se está acercando a la
ciudad de lis y chance
la gente que vive aquí se ha
acostumbrado al sonido de los
proyectiles que explotan dicen que
ningún lugar es seguro
pero
hubo una explosión luego la casa empezó
a temblar y los andamios cayeron al
suelo ni siquiera tuvimos tiempo de
entender lo que estaba pasando
a los tontos de ambos bandos tendrán que
llegar un acuerdo tarde o temprano
porque siempre son los inocentes los que
sufren
sin embargo lo peor podría estar por
llegar solo un río separa alice chang de
severodonezk una ciudad que se ha
convertido en el epicentro de los
esfuerzos rusos por capturar la región
del este del donbass los intensos
combates calle a calle han devastado lo
que se ha convertido en el último
bastión de resistencia ucraniana luján
si el alcalde dice que se han cortado la
electricidad y las comunicaciones más
lejos de la línea del frente en la
ciudad de bach mud la guerra se acerca
y algunos acusan al presidente
excelencia de abandonar el este se ha
olvidado del donbass solo se preocupa
por su piel se olvidó de las regiones de
donets y lugar otros ya han salido en
trenes especiales de evacuación
gestionados por las autoridades
ucranianas a medida que avanza el asalto
ruso no han tenido más remedio que huir
hacia el oeste para escapar de los
combates